[Music]
betta butta take a mocha Tom yawn huh my
single man told you care I just ate
Oh me huh okay well become yeah
okay we're back yummy yeah Oh real go
800 danube phonetic yeah
wait when there's a queue and yeah Nessa
q1 no my finish already it's quite cool
German there is a kid huh you gotta
Tomoko Tomoko Tomoko
dead Amazon tow communication all that
how many bad luck bed look better
hey am I done by Bachelet no oh you're
gonna die
how many Rachel's wonder [ __ ] salon
Gomorrah gotta do you have got a
birthday
no I don't but you're so handsome
you tickle ET emitte at OPA Tanya look
so like mom don't
I'm a but I don't want a rockin total to
Monday I can tell like into the hassle
we put it more risk
oh sure paycheck you know what dainty
I'm in such a hurry so cool you got peed
in there you are my favorite grandchild
I go to please icky I go I go to nekima
te I'll see you next week grandma don't
you talk oh yeah I'm gonna take what
terrible ah pop Tomoko huh
[Music]